[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi, and
welcome to episode 193
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mirchandani
and I'm here
with my colleague Michelle.
Hey, Michelle.
MICHELLE CASBON: Hey, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
How are you today?
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm great.
How are you?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm super-excited
about our upcoming interview.
Today is a very data science
focused day, wouldn't you say?
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
Today we have Chris
Albon with us.
He's a podcast veteran.
He is one of the
co-founders and co-hosts
of my personal favorite
podcast, "Partially Derivative."
This was my favorite
show from way back when.
This was the original
data science podcast.
Now it is no longer
running, and so
I've been sort of
teasing Chris like,
hey, you could revisit
your podcast days
and join us in the studio.
And we finally got him in today.
We're very excited.
He's here to share with
us many important nuggets.
One of my favorite is, what is
the most important predictor
of success in a data scientist?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And I would think
that the most important
predictor of success
for data science would be
able to science all the data.
MICHELLE CASBON: Of course.
However, Chris has
a different take,
and it's not what you think.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Apparently not,
because sciencing
all the data may not
be an easy thing to measure.
Well, super-excited
to get into that.
But before that, we also have
our question of the week.
What does the learn part of
machine learning actually mean?
MICHELLE CASBON: Are you
asking me how machines learn?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
mean, right-- they're
machines, right?
And when I think of
learning, I think
of like, studying and books
and maybe textbooks are
kind of out of date, but
I'm sure that people still
use them, right.
Like, they're all these
different concepts
that I have for my
education background.
You can't take a book and
smash it against a machine
until it knows the
stuff in there.
Right?
[METAL CLANGING]
Like, that's not
how machines learn.
[LAUGHING]
So how do they learn?
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's not by osmosis.
This is actually a pretty
difficult thing to describe,
but we'll go over it during
our question of the week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Before that though,
we have some really,
really cool things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I know you have outlined
some very fun data
science related stories
here, so let's jump into it.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
So I have a couple
of things that I want
to share with our audience.
The first one-- I do a lot
of talking about Kubeflow.
And one of the most
common questions I get
is, but how, Michelle?
How can you use Kubeflow to set
up a CI/CD pipeline for your ML
application?
We have a really cool article
this week on our blog,
and it talks about how
Itau Unibanco in Brazil--
so they're one of the
large banks in Brazil.
They give us a ton
of details about how
they built a CI/CD pipeline
for ML using Kubeflow.
So if you check
out the blog post,
they don't just talk
about why they did it,
but they give you
architecture diagrams,
and they talk about exactly
which tools they used.
So there's Jenkins
in there somewhere.
They're doing a lot of
this in a hybrid cloud,
multi-cloud setup.
So if you want to see
details, check that out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it sounds
like a fun way for people
to not only see what they're
doing, but also then to say,
well, you know, I can use
this to inspire my own CI/CD
pipeline for whatever
ML Kubeflow projects
I'm working on.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, that's right.
I really like this example,
because there's nothing
really specific to
being part of a bank.
I believe it's one of their
virtual assistant tools
that they use to speak
with their customers.
So all of these principles
apply to pretty much any ML
application.
One other thing that I really
liked is also from our blog.
And this is an article about why
TPUs are so high performance.
So we've talked about--
I think I've shared a
link to some code labs
before, that detail exactly
why TPUs are so interesting,
and some of the math
behind what makes
them so powerful for very
specific applications.
And so this article--
it's an explanation
of bfloat16, which
is kind of the secret
of the high performance
that you see with Cloud TPUs.
So it goes into some
of the math behind it,
and how TPUs take
advantage of that.
And what I like
about the article
is that the bfloat16 approach
uses mixed precision,
and that's suitable for
certain types of machine
learning algorithms,
and it's not very well
suited to other ones.
So this article
details the performance
that they saw using
different approaches.
And I also came across a
paper that some researchers
from Harvard published.
And they did some benchmarks.
So they looked at
the type of problems
that work best on CPUs
versus GPUs versus TPUs.
And they have a ton of details
on which type of problem
works best on TPUs, utilizing
this bfloat16 approach,
versus regular hardware
accelerators, GPUs,
something you'd see maybe from
NVIDIA, versus regular CPUs,
something that you can just
get on Google Compute Engine.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So it's a good way
to highlight why, when
you're thinking about machine
learning, there's certainly the
aspect of building your code
and having it run, and of course
you need to train these models.
And a lot of that-- it tends to
be computationally expensive.
And so when you use GPUs
to kind of speed that up,
you're also making a
sacrifice, because GPUs
are really good at
doing some things,
but not necessarily all the
things that a CPU can do.
And it sounds like TPU,
or tensor processing units
are very much even further
down that line of, they're
really, really good at a
certain narrow set of things,
and less good at other things.
So I think some clarity
on when to use which ones
and how you might
focus on it and say,
well this is a great
example of something
where we can kind of
fine-tune for a TPU,
or maybe this is something we
want to stay general and keep
it just to GPUs.
You can kind of
make those decisions
with more information about
where the pros and cons are.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
Yeah and just like
in any field, you
want to make sure
that you're using
the right tool for the job.
And this is one way to help you.
How do you know if you're
using the right algorithm?
Let's take a step
back and if I know
that for TPUs I should be using
a certain class of algorithms.
But if I want to start
writing those algorithms,
where do I go to figure
out what my options are?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I don't
know, but by the way
you're looking at me, I
feel like you have an answer
to the question you just asked.
MICHELLE CASBON: So my last
[INAUDIBLE] of the week
is machine learning flashcards.
This is something that I
came across a few years ago.
And they are a set of just
hundreds of popular algorithms,
really sort of classic
approaches in statistics.
And this is a set of cards
that explains each one of them.
And they're really
beautifully handwritten,
hand-created by our special
guest today, Chris Albon.
What I really like about
them is that they give you
very clear and
concise definitions.
So some of them
explain the difference
between supervised and
unsupervised learning.
There's also overfitting
versus underfitting, linear
versus logistic regression.
So pretty common topics
in machine learning.
It gives you the statistical
background for it,
and just a little refresher.
It's not going to explain
the whole concept for you,
but if you've learned it
before, it's a really good way
to just refresh things.
So some of the other
cards that I really
like-- you get definitions for
things like receiver operating
characteristic, if you've ever
wondered what the ROC curve is.
That's the acronym.
That's what it stands for.
He tells us all about Occam's
razor, Simpson's paradox,
explains softmax normalization,
even the RELU activation
function, the
rectified linear units.
So if you've ever
wondered about those,
his flashcards can give
you all the details.
And I want to talk about
my very favorite flashcard.
If you download
this set from him,
make sure you check out the
random forest flashcard,
because it's the
most beautifully
illustrated, and best
explanation of my favorite type
of classification.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I
understand very, very little
of this world.
So I'm thinking that I
need to brush up on it.
And it sounds like the
flashcards are a great way
to do that.
But they're really meant
more as supplemental material
to helping learn.
And I think, we kind
of talked a little bit
about how people are using these
to brush up for interviews.
And they're just a great
way to kind of practice
your knowledge of
these different terms,
different methods,
different algorithms, all
throughout machine
learning as a whole.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
think that's super-exciting.
I'm probably going to go order
some right after we finish
this, because I
definitely do not
know what random forest
classifier means, or even
have a concept of it.
But I'm hoping the picture
is of a pretty forest.
MICHELLE CASBON: The
pictures will help.
You'll be an expert in no time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
remains to be seen.
[LAUGHING]
Well, speaking of experts,
I think we are really
excited to talk to Chris.
So let's dive right into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Welcome.
Today we have an
amazing guest that I've
been trying to get here
into the studio for months,
if not years.
It's been a while.
I'm glad we could finally
get this scheduled.
Chris, it is fantastic
to have you here.
This is your first time
in a podcast studio ever.
CHRIS ALBON: I think this
is the first time I've been
in an actual podcast studio.
It's pretty cobbled together.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Whoa.
Whoa.
MICHELLE CASBON: What
are you talking about?
This is a pro setup.
[LAUGHING]
CHRIS ALBON: No, no, no.
Don't get me wrong.
This is way better
than everything
I've ever used before.
But I recognize
everything in this room.
So, like, I don't know.
I feel like if you go
on some radio show,
they should have all
these fancy things.
But this is all the same setup,
it was just in my, you know,
closet.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
what you're saying is,
this is all the good stuff,
but also it's efficient.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
Well thank you.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
That's definitely--
that's what you get,
is the efficiency, as opposed
to setting your own setup up.
Like, oh, OK, like, my
wife is gone for an hour,
and you start, like, unfurling
all these like, egg crate sound
things, like a crazy person.
No, this is definitely faster
than what we used to do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well I'm
glad that you enjoy the setup.
I think we've got a
lot to talk about.
But to kick things off,
Chris, why don't you
tell us a little bit about
yourself and what you do.
CHRIS ALBON: Sure.
I am the Director
of Data Science
for Devoted Health, which is
a Medicare Advantage startup.
So it is a health
insurance company.
That's what everyone asks me.
Everyone's like oh, yeah,
you're like a health startup.
Like you should probably
use AI to connect people
to health insurance companies.
Like, no, no, no.
This is like a regular
health insurance company
that we started from scratch.
So it's like, you
know, like actual cards
from the health insurance
company like, the full setup.
And it's a really interesting
experience from a data science
perspective, because you come
in with very little knowledge
of how health insurance
actually works in America.
And then you sit down
and then you actually
talk to a bunch of experts
who work [INAUDIBLE]
and you go, oh, wow,
this is complicated.
This is super-complicated.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
don't think anyone's
dealt with American
insurance and been
like, no, that was easy.
[LAUGHING]
No.
This is all straightforward.
You'll figure it
out in a day or two.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
Well that was the thing.
When I joined, or
before I joined,
I did a bunch of reading of
these like, general audience
books on insurance.
And I was thinking
I was pretty smart.
And then DJ Patil, my
boss, was like, how much
you think you know.
You know nothing.
And now I realize, like, oh,
oh, this is crazy complicated.
MICHELLE CASBON:
So are you saying
that that was actually
a harder thing
to learn than the
data science side?
CHRIS ALBON: Oh, yeah.
No, I mean, I actually think
the specialty on our team
is taking folks who are very,
very strong in data science,
and then teaching
them about Medicare,
and teaching them
about health insurance.
Because there's a whole other
realm of information in there.
And it's something that
we take very seriously.
Because if you do
the analysis wrong,
like you can actually
affect people's care, right,
in a real way.
This is how people get
their health insurance.
This is how they
pay for the doctor.
This is how they get
their prescription drugs.
And if you do something wrong,
we have to know immediately,
and we have to fix it.
And so bringing
people on and saying,
hey, let's teach
you about Medicare,
let's teach you about Medicare
Advantage, that kind of stuff
is actually a lot of what we do.
We have a lot of
educational sessions.
We have a lot of, like--
we actually have a
channel in our Slack.
So we use Slack for our
company communication.
We actually have a
channel where people are
allowed to ask any question.
You can ask any, any, any
question that you want.
You can ask as many
times as you want.
You can ask for clarification.
And the idea behind
the whole thing
is to say, no, don't
assume that you know it.
Just ask someone.
And, you know, that's how
we'll work this thing out.
Because there have
been cases of startups
who come into the
health insurance base,
that they made some assumption.
And that assumption ended
up hurting people's care,
because they decided that
a high number was good,
and in fact a high number's bad.
Right.
And then that, like,
effects people's ability
to go to the doctor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's
kind of like three-parted
in the approach that
people need to take.
Right?
Because there's this classic
data science background,
full of best practices
and tips, and there's
kind of a general
understanding of what that is.
But you can't really
work in this industry
without also knowing
the second part, which
is going to be all the
health care specific data,
the nuances, the people
you're working with.
And then the third
part I'm guessing
is going to be a lot of
regulation around that.
So, I mean, like, you
know, if you're coming in
and you've been a data
scientist for 20 years,
you know a lot of this stuff,
you're not fully prepared
to take this on without
additional training,
additional understanding.
You can't just dive in.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
No, it's this
amazing thing where
obviously Medicare is for
people who are 65 and older.
We basically have no one on
staff who's 65 years or older.
So we can't dog
food our own thing.
Like my health insurance
from the company
is not my own health
insurance, despite the fact
we are a health
insurance company.
And one of the most
important things that we do,
which was actually
started by DJ,
was that we have data science
folks actually go to the field.
So for example, like,
I flew down to Florida
and actually visited
doctor's offices.
Actually we have
our own doctors,
so I actually went
on a patient visit
and sat in one of our member's
houses while one of our doctors
actually did after
hospitalization.
And the idea is to make it real.
Right.
Like this isn't
just a data point.
This isn't something
where you think
what you're talking about.
Like, go and sit down
and see it on the ground,
and see the reality, and then go
back and work from that point.
Like, do the analyses
from that point.
Build the models
And if, in health insurance,
if you don't have that,
I don't think you
could do the job.
I don't know how it would work.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
what was your motivation
for joining Devoted?
I know you may be new
to health insurance,
but you're not new
to health care.
Right?
CHRIS ALBON: No.
So my background is
in humanitarian tech.
So I worked with a number
of Kenyan nonprofits
like Ushahidi and
FrontlineSMS, and did things
like election monitoring
and global health projects.
And after that I
spun out a company
with a few of my friends who
I used to work with Ushahidi,
that now works on fake news
stuff, called New Knowledge.
And then I went back
after my startup
and went back and worked for
a Kenyan social good program.
And so my whole background is
in doing some things that have
some kind of social impact.
That's the thing that I
have had the privilege
of doing for a very long time.
And there was just this
one day where DJ, you know,
called me up.
And he was like,
hey, I really need
you to help me fix Medicare.
And I was like [BLEEP].
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh yeah.
CHRIS ALBON: Can I
swear on this podcast?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
CHRIS ALBON: I think that
was basically my reaction.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Of course.
Yeah, I mean, that's no--
as we just talked about,
that's not an easy thing to do.
I mean, there's plenty of
issues with it currently,
and there's a lot
of concerns there.
But it's also an
incredibly complex field.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
And that was my big
thing coming in was like,
I'm not trying to
improve everything.
fix everything.
I'm not trying to do--
but if I could take
one step and make
it a little bit better, right.
Like if we could build something
that we would want, as Devoted
says in their slogan, like,
that you'd want your own family
members to be on,
then you're good.
Right.
Like that's it.
Just one step forward
that's a little bit better,
that's a little bit nicer,
that has a little bit more,
you know, like, a
health insurance company
with a bit of a soul.
Great.
We've pushed the bar forward.
People's lives are better.
The grand sweeping
change is far beyond my--
[LAUGHING]
--my ability to fix.
MICHELLE CASBON: So you're not
taking your global health care
perspective and applying that
to the American health insurance
industry?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
No, no.
I mean, I think the
thing that I take
from it is a really, really,
really strong humility
towards my own assumptions.
Right.
When you work at
a Kenyan company
or what I was doing, like
flying down to Mozambique
and doing some project, you
have to trust the people
on the ground.
They know what it's like to
work in those environments.
They know what it's
like, like how far they
can push the government before
the government retaliates.
Like, they know all that stuff.
And so you have to
come in as someone
who knows a lot about data
and can manipulate data
and can work with them, but
basing that on their knowledge.
And that's what I've really
tried to instill with my team
at Devoted is, hey, we
have all these people
who've been working in this
industry for a long time.
We have a bunch of providers
in the field who know
what it's like to be in there.
Like, trust the
person in the field.
Trust their knowledge.
Help them and support them,
but don't walk in and say,
there's some logistic
regression that's
going to solve all of this.
Let me just figure
out which one it is.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think
that's like the ultimate form
of advocacy is that true-- not
only that level of empathy,
but also that level of just
connecting with your audience
and working with them to say,
look, you know your area,
I know my area.
Let's combine that.
Let's make something happen.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
The really fun thing
about data science
is, you have the ability to
work in a whole bunch of areas
and work with data.
And you can, in a bad way,
come to the assumption
that you could fix everything,
that you understand
how the data is generated.
So you understand how the
data model works, and thus you
could figure out
every single thing,
and you can come up with
these grand theories,
and then write a model
and it fits them.
And then you say, hey, I'm done.
Right.
We're good.
And that's not true
in a lot of cases.
Right.
Like, your assumptions
for how the world works
is not true, unless
you've gone and seen it,
unless you've talked
to a lot of people,
unless you've sort of done
the legwork to figure it out.
And we try to do that a lot.
I think one of the greatest
things of working at Devoted
is the large number
of people that we
have who have worked in Medicare
Advantage for a long time,
which means that I can
go to them and be like,
I don't understand how
this thing happens.
I'm constantly asking like,
the really stupid questions.
Because otherwise I'm terrified
of not getting it right.
MICHELLE CASBON: During
your time at Devoted
you came in pretty early
on, and you built things up
from scratch.
Tell us a little
bit about what it
was like to come in, not knowing
a whole lot about the space,
and asking the right
questions, and making sure
that you stayed on track.
What was that building up
a data science team like?
How did you go from
zero to something?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So when I came in, there was,
I think three data scientists,
all under DJ.
And then DJ moved to
the head of technology,
and so then I took over
the data science team.
And we had to sit down,
me a DJ, and say, hey,
like, what's the kind of
team that we want to build?
Right.
There's a variety
of ways that you
can implement data science
at any kind of company,
from scratch.
Do you have the data
scientist sort of sit
in the corner as a research lab?
Do you make the I-team just
takes tickets, and just
processes the tickets, and then
sends out the dashboard that
makes it work?
Those were both valid
in very common ways.
We decided to go for the
fully integrated approach.
So every single data
scientist at Devoted
works in at least one other
team-- like actual teams that
are working on specific things,
like, say, processing claims,
or saying, talking
to our doctors.
They sit in those meetings
and they are the data science
resource in those meetings.
And that means that no one
has to submit a ticket when
they want to get something
done on data science.
They just tap the person
on the shoulder who's
sitting in their
meeting and say, hey,
you know, like, Jason,
fix this for me.
That is super powerful.
And I think that fits
our model of making sure
that the people who are
working in data science
actually know the subject
matter that they're working on.
That kind of stuff, plus a
thousand other decisions, those
were the decisions that you
make when you start a team.
Like, how do you
want to structure it?
How do you want to
build out this thing?
How many people do you want?
What's the seniority of people?
And like walking
through that, slowly,
is my job all the time now.
MICHELLE CASBON: And did you
organize things that way?
So are people reporting
to the subject area teams?
Or do you still have the
data scientists under you,
and then everyone just sort
of belongs to another team?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah, so
everyone is under me.
And then we lend them
out to the other teams.
And they'll jump
around a few times.
But the goal is that if someone
is working on something that
needs data science, they
don't need to come to me
and say, hey, can I get
a resource for this?
Or I submitted a Jira ticket
to make this thing work.
They can actually say,
no, no, no, you know,
they've been sitting
in our meeting
for weeks and weeks and weeks.
They can totally understand
what's happening.
They understand the
nuances of this.
Let's just have them do it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
based on your description,
I mean, it sounds like it's
a pretty successful model.
Like that's something
that works pretty well
for getting those teams, not
only access to the data science
resources that they need, but
also getting those data science
resources more ingrained with
what the solution looks like,
or actually the different
pieces that they're working on.
Are there some challenges to
this that other people aren't
picking up this same structure?
Or is that the same reason why?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah, no.
I think there's definitely
some challenges.
Like one of the ones that
we deal with is that--
I think we have nine data
scientists now under me.
You know, we're
everywhere in Devoted
all over the organization.
And it means a lot of times
there's only a single data
scientist sitting in a meeting.
So sometimes those
data scientists
could actually be the lone
resource for something.
And that means that it can be a
situation where they don't feel
like they get
support, and we need
to make sure that we
actively encourage that.
That is a real problem.
I mean, the other
one, of course,
is that managing a group of
people who are nine people who
are across like, 15 different
projects across the company,
means that I jump around
all over the place.
I'm in all aspects of
what the company does,
only for like five-minute
segments before I
go on to the next part.
It is like anything else
with cost and benefits.
I wouldn't do it another way
at a company like Devoted,
but I completely see
the value if, like, you
were more of a product company,
like a straight technology
product company, to actually
have everyone sit in one room,
and then bust out the Jira
board and say, OK, cool,
like I'm going to manage
what every single person does
[INAUDIBLE].
We're in fact like, I am
doing a lot more coordinating.
I'm doing a lot
more, like, guidance.
I'm doing a lot more,
like, hey, if you
need to pull the
emergency ejection handle,
like, call me in and
I'll help you out
with this kind of stuff.
That is like a new
structure, and I
think we do it pretty well.
But we are learning all the time
about how we can do it better.
We do retros, so we do, like,
retrospectives of the last two
weeks, every two weeks.
So we're constantly, like,
sending cells like, how well
are we doing this thing?
Because there isn't a lot
of guidebooks about that.
There's no standard
structure for this.
We're still figuring
this stuff out.
MICHELLE CASBON: Number one,
how do you scale that approach?
Do you see that changing?
Like, Devoted's
pretty hyper growth.
And having nine
people under you,
like, you can still manage
that as a single person,
but very quickly you'll
to have other people.
So number one, how do you scale?
And then also, like, as an IC,
how do I not get overwhelmed?
Like how do I actually
get work done,
instead of getting
sort of dragged
into a lot of the
business details?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
I mean, the interesting thing
about being in a company that
is hyper growth--
and I really feel
like that is very,
like, a tech bro
saying or something like that.
[LAUGHING]
But, I mean, it's
true at Devoted.
Like, when I joined
Devoted there
was something like 60 people.
And our last incoming class
of folks was 50 people.
So like, just massive growth.
MICHELLE CASBON: Those
are large numbers.
CHRIS ALBON: Those
There's a lot more people who
are joining every single day.
And as we grow, there has to
be more structure in place.
And the thing that I really
am fighting for a lot
and trying to restructure in
a way that works for that,
is to allow us to
cover everything,
but also to allow our data
scientists to sit down and work
on something for a
long period of time.
You know, it almost feels
like zone defense, right.
You're like, just
covering everything.
Then someone comes over and
taps you on the shoulder
and says, hey, could
you just do this for me?
And you stop what you're
doing and you help them out
for three hours.
And then someone else
taps you on the shoulder.
As opposed to
saying, hey, this is
a big, long, difficult
project that I'm going
to work on for four months.
Don't bother me.
We're trying to like, split
up a team a little bit
so we actually folks
that are doing more,
like, able to be
distracted by anything.
You know, if anybody wants to
come and ask a question, they
can come and help,
while other folks are
sitting down and
actually working
on stuff for long winds,
right, big, longer winds.
And probably build that out
more and more as time goes on,
because you do want to make
sure that we are covering
the needs for everything.
Also, there are some larger
wins like things like ML
and that kind of
stuff that we're just
starting to build
into, which require
a lot longer process before
you actually see value from it.
Right.
You have to build out this whole
infrastructure of how you train
the models and manage
the models and then
apply 'em to our system.
That takes time.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes.
I have so many questions
about that, in fact.
But before we get on
to the infrastructure
that you're using and what
your stack looks like,
I am curious in
hearing more about
how you've grown your team.
So with all of these people that
are coming in, some of those
are data scientists.
How have you been purposeful
about who you hire,
who you bring onto the team?
What have been your
driving factors in building
out your team?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So when you do the
fully integrated model,
one of the things that I had
a hypothesis of the start,
which has played
out very well, is
that your data scientists
need to have really
high emotional intelligence.
They need to be able
to sit on other teams.
Other teams need to
want them to come in
and say, hey, like, come
sit in my meeting, right.
If you walk in and you're a
detriment to their meeting,
they're not going to invite
you to come in again, right.
They're not going
to want you to join
the team, like sit in
with them while they are
trying to get their work done.
MICHELLE CASBON: I think that's
my favorite quote of like,
the last year is that
your people need to have
high emotional intelligence.
You don't hear people
talking about that.
So you've taken a
purposeful approach to that.
How have you done that?
How have you substantiated that?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So it's part of our
interview process.
So, like, we do a
number of things,
but the one that
actually works really
well is that for us, anyone
who interviews someone
or talks to someone, or
does any kind of thing
with any candidate has
full veto right to say,
I don't want to
work this person.
Like, this person probably
wouldn't be good for me,
and I'll nix 'em.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
CHRIS ALBON: I'll
remove 'em right away.
And that offer, when
people are talking to 'em--
you know, when one of
my folks is actually
talking to a candidate,
that offer from me to say,
hey, if you have any--
you don't even need
to like, you know, do
some elaborate
explanation as to why.
If you don't feel like you
can work with that person,
let's just get rid of 'em
and find someone else.
It is incredibly important,
because the fully integrated
model that we do,
doesn't work if you're
the brilliant [BLEEP].
It's not something
that works really well
because if you come
in and, you know,
someone is a very
good coder, which
I'm not sure the brilliant
[BLEEP] like actually
exists in reality.
But like, if someone comes in
and they are very, very smart,
but no one wants
to work with them,
it harms the team
internally, because people
don't want to ask those
stupid questions, which
is so critical when
you're learning
a new field like
Medicare Advantage.
And other people at the company
don't want to work with them,
thus they don't invite 'em in.
They don't ask me to
like, send someone
on to their team to help
them out with a problem.
And so are very, very
careful with that.
And I don't have,
obviously my team
sitting in this room with
me, but if you actually
looked at the team you'd see
that people are very kind
and very honest and very open.
And that's something that
we've selected for, explicitly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: How do
you give advice to people
to avoid that specific
problem, or to avoid
becoming that problem?
Because I think it's a
stereotype that we all
have heard of, like the rock
star developer or the rock data
scientist-- whatever
it is, right.
Like this idea that
someone knows enough
that they can just go off
and do their own thing,
and they don't need other
people to help them.
I think it's common enough
that people know about it,
and it can be a really difficult
trap for people to fall into.
What advice do
you give to people
to say, like, don't
become this person?
CHRIS ALBON: I think
the easiest way
that people fall in it is
when the data science team is
actually isolated from the rest
of the organization-- right,
if they're a research
shop off in the corner,
it is so easy to fall into
that, because you're not
selecting that.
On an everyday basis
you don't need people
with lots and lots of
emotional intelligence
if there's just four
engineers sitting in a room.
I think in reality
you do, but that's
the common perception,
right, that you could
find four great coders
and put 'em in the room
and call it a day.
That's not actually
the case, but when
it becomes a fully
integrated model and people
are actually working
with non-technical folks
throughout the
organization, and have
to respect those people's
knowledge, right.
They've been working in
this space for 20 years,
you can't really be
condescending to them
in any way.
Right.
They know what they're doing.
You're there to
support 'em, and you
can be an equal partner
in that, and challenge
some of their ideas,
but you do have
to respect their knowledge.
Being technical is not the
advantage in this space.
And when you have that, it
becomes very, very obvious,
very, very quickly that not
having emotional intelligence,
and not being able
to work with folks
in that way is a detriment.
It's very, very quick that you
realize that that doesn't work.
I get it that there's another
scenario where it's harder
to see, right, because
some of the engineers
just don't work as well, because
there's some brilliant [BLEEP]
in the room or
something like that.
It's harder as the manager TO
normally see that as the case,
right.
Because the other engineers
basically close their mouth.
They don't really talk about it.
They just kind of like,
work in a certain way
that it's not optimal, but
they don't really express it.
When technical folks are
working with non-technical folks
throughout the organization
it becomes really obvious.
And so I get it that
people fall into this trap.
It's totally reasonable.
I think being in any kind
of technology organization,
there's like the
technical side, right.
There's the code and the
servers and the config
files and all that stuff, and
then there's a social machine.
There's this other part of
people's goals and desires
and emotions and all
that kind of stuff.
And if you don't
address that, you're
not going to be
everywhere in the company.
Right.
You're not going to be doing
the best that you could do.
And that part of it--
If I had some like, lasting
lesson from this whole thing
as I go forward is that
focusing on the social machine
explicitly, like making sure
that all your folks can work
with everyone, is a
game-changer that's
completely unappreciated.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, I
totally agree with that.
It's not something that
people talk about much.
But in my experience as
well, if you can't get along,
if you don't have kindness
and respect in the workplace,
people who would otherwise
be very brilliant,
just get sort of
quieted, and they're
afraid to ask the
right questions.
And that means that the business
case doesn't get addressed.
So thank you for talking about
that, for bringing that up.
What are some ways that
you can support your teams?
If you have a group of
people in a room that
have respect for each other
and are kind to each other
and are brilliant, can
address the business problems,
how do you support them
in that and make sure
that they continue
to be comfortable,
that they can continue to grow?
What are some things that
you do for your team?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So two of them I
do very clearly.
One, I'm the first person
to ask the dumbest question.
Like, I'm very, very explicit
I do not know everything
about Medicare Advantage.
I know a lot.
I know way more than
the average person.
I work in this every single day.
I've spent a lot of time
learning this stuff,
and I'm still learning
stuff, and I'm very
open to something I don't know.
I'm not pretending I know every
single fact that comes in.
I will ask it if
I don't know it.
And being the senior
person in the room who
is open and available
to ask that question,
of which some of my team
actually know the answer,
and they can actually
answer to me--
that is a big deal.
Like being the first
person that comes in--
and when we did the Slack
channel that actually allowed
everyone to answer
every question,
I was the first people
to ask the question.
I'm happy to go in and say,
I don't know something.
That your senior folks
are asking those questions
is the big deal.
The other one is to be
very explicit about it.
You don't need to be
coy about the fact
that you value
emotional intelligence
or like, some kind
of like, social game.
Just say it explicitly, like,
we value emotional intelligence
in this company because
you need to do your job.
In order to do your job
the best way possible,
you need to do that.
You need to go and
relate with people.
You need to be able
to work with people.
People need to like you
and want to work with you.
That is an explicit
thing that we value,
and I say it
explicitly to my folks.
If you don't do that, I don't
understand how that works.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
That's amazing.
You're looking at
hiring a few people.
And I looked at your job
ad and I've never seen
so many instances
of the word, like,
"love," and "care,"
in a tech job.
Ad I was really blown away.
It's clear, not just
having this conversation,
but it's clear how
the company is run.
Like, this is a thing
that we care about,
that we're explicit about it.
I'm glad that's working for you.
Keep doing it.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And it sounds
like a lot of these things,
you know, you may have
practiced and learned
before you came to
Devoted, because you
have quite a, kind of a
storied history, as it were.
CHRIS ALBON:
[INAUDIBLE] history.
[LAUGHING]
OK, Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, well, that's the
best term I can come up--
I don't know if you
have a preferred term.
CHRIS ALBON: No.
I just-- I've never
been "storied," I guess.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well I'd
love to hear a little bit more
about how you became
a data scientist,
or how you decided that this
was the right route for you.
And you had mentioned earlier
all the different organizations
you had worked with.
So I'm sure there's a tremendous
amount of like, cool background
there.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So I did my PhD in political
science at UC Davis.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Wait a second.
Poly Sci isn't data science.
CHRIS ALBON: Uh huh.
See, so I dragged this in here.
UC Davis is a quantitative
political science program.
So I don't know--
like, honestly, I
have no idea who Kant is.
Like I have the vaguest
idea who Kant is.
Like Rousseau is like
a name that I've heard,
but like, everything else--
I did statistics, right.
Statistics was everything.
That was applied statistics
was my whole education for six
years.
When I was doing that PhD,
I got to know some folks who
were working at LinkedIn.
And this includes DJ and this
includes a few other folks.
And they were doing
such cool applied stuff
that I knew I wanted to
leave academia and do it.
They were doing so many
interesting things, a lot of it
with [INAUDIBLE] at
the time, but a lot
of really interesting stuff.
And when I saw that I knew
that I wanted to leave academia
and work on that kind of stuff.
And so when I got out I
talked to a friend of mine
who was working at a US-UK
Kenyan nonprofit called
FrontlineSMS that did low
resource SMS messaging
for, like, election monitoring
and that kind of stuff.
And I was like, I
want a job, Frank.
Give me a job.
And that was an incredibly
humbling experience,
as someone who thought
of themselves as like, I
have a PhD, I'm amazing.
And then you fly over to
Morocco and then you're like,
oh, like--
MICHELLE CASBON: I have no idea.
CHRIS ALBON: I have no idea
what's happening, right.
And, you know, the most humbling
experience of that, by far,
was that we would do trainings
with folks and teach 'em how
to use--
our software as free and
open-source, and so we'd teach
'em how to use it.
And we'd give them some, like,
physical pieces of hardware
to help 'em do it.
And doing those trainings,
it became very explicit
over the years in my mind,
this and at Ushahidi, which
was the next place I worked--
if the cops kind of burst down
the room, right, like the cops
sort of swarmed in
and do it, you know,
and really arrested everyone,
I was going to get on a plane,
right.
They were just going to put me
on a plane and fly back home
and that was going to
be the end of everything
and it wouldn't
really be a big deal.
But for the other--
like the local folks
in the room, the folks who
were living in that country
and can't leave and were on
the radar of the government
for the whole time and didn't
have the protection of the US
embassy, it was going to
be a very, very big deal.
And taking their security
concerns into account,
we would use all this
training material
and then burn it in a bonfire.
So there was like
physically nothing there--
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
CHRIS ALBON: --that
someone else could do.
But having that respect
for the other person.
Like saying like, hey,
like, I know a lot.
I know a lot about data science.
I get there's lots
of hype around it.
AI is super cool, all
that kind of stuff,
and yet the person in the
field, the person in the room,
they're putting a lot on the
line, right, to work with you.
And having respect for that
and understanding that,
and respecting their
knowledge of these things
is by far the greatest lesson
that I learned, doing that
for a good number of years.
MICHELLE CASBON: Because
it doesn't necessarily
matter what the application is.
Being able to respect
the user experience
and understand what
they're going through
and where they're
vulnerable, and you're really
being entrusted with access
to parts of their lives
that could endanger them.
And it sounds like
every data scientist
should have an experience
that really helps
them connect with their
users, and really respect
the access that they have.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
And I think it applies,
you know, well beyond--
I mean, these are very serious
cases like election monitoring
and health programs.
But in my mind it
applies everywhere.
If you work at a food
delivery company, like,
you really need to understand
how people are using it.
Like, you know, you
might think that it's
a 22-year-old who's using
it to get beer after work.
But, in fact, it's like
someone on maternity
leave and they have
two kids and they're
trying to-- you know,
they're just struggling
and they just really,
really want it, and try
to understand their
perspective and their wants.
I can't think of doing it
another way that would work.
It seems arrogant.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well
it's kind of clear that,
like, especially from that
experience why you brought that
into Devoted.
And it sounds like the big
part of the culture there.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
No.
And that was something that DJ
and I were very explicit about,
that we need to-- don't
assume that you understand
our members' lives.
Right.
So, you know, Medicare
Advantage and Medicare
are provided to every
single American over 65,
so people who are rich and
people are poor, and so don't
understand what you know the
significance of a $5 copay is,
right.
That might be
nothing for someone,
and it might be a
lot for someone.
And so don't build models
that assume that you
know the value of that.
That kind of stuff happens
every single day, right,
making sure that we know that.
And, you know, sometimes
I think we stumble a bit,
and sometimes I
think we crush it.
But just making sure we do
it better every single day,
that is what we
are selecting on.
The technical stuff
we can train out.
There's tons of people who
are super technical and super
awesome.
We are trying to get people
who can come in and really
make sure that they
understand the user.
MICHELLE CASBON: Mm-hmm.
So what advice would
you give to someone
who's looking for a role
on a team like yours?
Someone who cares
about their users, who
places more value on the
impact that they have,
rather than just the
technology that they're using.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
You know, it's an
interesting thing,
because we get a lot of
applicants to our jobs.
And a good number of them are
really trying to, probably--
I mean it seems weird
saying this at Google,
but trying to please Google
with a very, very, very
technical analysis.
Right.
Like, we're going
straight to, like,
some kind of computer
vision, like, you know,
adversarial network kind of
example or something like that.
And that might totally
get people jobs
in different places.
It doesn't get people
jobs at Devoted.
Right.
That's not something--
I much, much,
much prefer to have
people coming in
and can demonstrate
really good consciousness
of what the project
they're working on.
So say if you're
analyzing crime data
in San Francisco or
something like that, just,
like, running the analysis
and then showing me
a chart isn't really
a-- like, who cares?
Right.
Like, I can do that.
Everyone can do that.
But going the next step
and say, hey, no, I
implemented something.
Like I did something.
I went out and took this data
and I gave it to some reporter,
and they got an
article published,
or some kind of thing to
actually have some kind of--
I'm not even saying
you need to make
some massive difference for it.
But everyone can
run some analysis
on some kind of publicly
available data set
and demonstrate
some basic skill.
Right now, like-- maybe
like five or six years ago
that was a great way
of getting a job.
Now everyone's doing that.
But something where
I can actually say,
hey, no, this person
clearly understands
this difficult
phenomenon, whether social
or physical or whatever.
That's incredibly valuable
for me, because I can then
take that person
and say, hey, I'm
going to put you
into an environment
that you don't know
anything about.
You don't really know about the
lives of people who are over 65
and really poor in Florida.
I will help you learn it.
But you need to be an active
participant in that learning,
and to like, sit and
actually think that this
is an important thing to learn.
And we'll walk our
way through it.
MICHELLE CASBON: So it's
about having a full story,
so starting out on a project
being intentional about what
you're doing and
why you're doing it,
and then following
through with--
the technical piece is
only one part of it.
And it's important, but
what's more important
is the larger frame
for that story.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
And if you had something-- like
say, to take the crime example.
If you analyze crime
data, like, if you
did some ground truthings, like
you went to the police station
and like, checked to
make sure things were--
like you pulled a few
records or something
like that to see if it
actually matched-- something
where you can actually
say, no, no, I'm digging
a little bit deeper into this.
And everything, again,
like, I'm not saying, hey,
you have to do some massive
social good project for you
to work at Devoted,
but I am saying
that the value of
running an analysis
is no longer straight
that you just
did some simple
machine learning thing,
because everyone's done
that at this point.
Every single person
who applies to Devoted
has an example of that.
But that part where you've
gone a little bit farther
and you've kind of done
some ground truthing
or you've looked into
something or like,
you've really tried to
understand the situation,
like, that stands
out so quickly to me.
MICHELLE CASBON:
So you're saying
that FizzBuzz and
TensorFlow is not going
to get you a job at Devoted.
CHRIS ALBON: It will not
get you a job at Devoted.
Although I did like Joel Grus'
FizzBuzz using deep learning.
MICHELLE CASBON: Oh,
he has so many more.
Have you seen his--
yeah.
He does it on, like, notebooks.
He has so much more
where that came from.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
I do like Joel.
MICHELLE CASBON:
He's pretty great.
CHRIS ALBON: That was the
example where I was like,
there's no way-- like if someone
came in using deep learning
to do a very, very simple
program example like--
I mean it's funny, but it's
not what I'm looking for.
MICHELLE CASBON: It's very Joel.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's more
than about just the technology.
It's really about applying
it and making, you know,
and hopefully inciting
change because of it,
but also doing kind of
the active participation
in what you're trying to
do the technology around.
But let's talk a little bit
more about the technology
too, because that part
is also important, right.
And that is a good
chunk of, you know,
needing to understand
data science
and being able to execute on it.
CHRIS ALBON: I mean that's
the baseline, right.
If I don't have that,
you're no real discussion.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So what does that stack
look like a Devoted?
And what technologies
do you find
to be the most
interesting or useful?
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So one of the most
interesting things at Devoted
that you wouldn't realize
if you saw on the outside
is that we have built our own
system for running an insurance
company.
So we actually
have an application
that we call Orinoco
that actually
runs the whole insurance
company, right,
everything from processing
claims to managing member
calls, all that kind of stuff.
And the plus side
of that is that we
control that whole system.
So if one of our
members calls, we
have very easy access
to all the information
that we have on 'em,
because they're not
in 10 different systems.
They're in, like, one system.
The downside of that is that
that system is very complex.
MICHELLE CASBON: That
takes a lot of support.
CHRIS ALBON: It's a very,
very, very complex system.
It's also a very new system,
because we're a young company.
And so, you know, there isn't 20
years of documentation sitting.
Under those, like, for us
on the data science team,
that data comes down and
actually gets replicated down
to Snowflake and
then we're mostly
working on the Snowflake layer.
That kind of stack,
you know, that's
a very like, standard stack.
It works very well.
I think it's difficult for folks
to actually come in and try
to work in that Orinoco
app and understand
the data that comes out.
Because I think we
have something--
we have like 1,000
tables or something
like that that comes out
of this piece of software.
And it's so powerful if you
learn that whole data model,
but learning that
data model's not easy.
It's not obvious how
everything works.
You really have to
sit down and like,
look at other people's,
like, queries,
and look at other people's
code and be like, oh, I get it.
That's how that works.
And that's not an
unusual problem,
compared to everyone else.
Right.
There was this great
article a few months ago
that was like some
other large company.
And they tried to do
a basic, like a sum,
like the ages of all of their
members or something like that.
And it turns out that
even that calculation
was incredibly difficult
to actually do,
because the data is
all over the place,
and to get historic
data, and the data models
change over time, and
all that kind of stuff.
But yeah, at Devoted we use
Snowflake for our stack,
and then we use
Periscope for analytics,
which is super nice
if you know SQL,
because you can just grind out
a lot of charts really fast.
And a lot of Airflow
is thrown in there,
Kubernetes, that kind of stuff.
A pretty typical startup
stack, I feel like.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK.
And as you were building
that out, did you
spend more time on the
actual building of the stack,
or figuring out what to build?
CHRIS ALBON: We
were lucky enough
that we hired a lot
of senior folks.
So a lot of our folks--
for example, like
Carla [INAUDIBLE],,
who's my partner in
data engineering,
so my peer in data engineering.
She built out a lot
of stuff at RunKeeper.
She was like really
high up at RunKeeper
and built out
their whole system.
So when she came in to run
data engineering at Devoted,
she really knew what
she was going for.
And that's the same thing
we did with data science.
Right.
I've sort of seen
these things before.
It's not my first
rodeo in these,
being one of the early
data science hires.
And so we kind of knew what we
wanted to build, and we we'd
seen these patterns before,
and we can apply 'em.
That part has been super useful.
It means that you have a lot of
folks with a lot of experience,
and you can ask them how
the best way to do it.
They've tried all the
wrong ways previously,
and they can decide
on the right way.
But it is part of
the Devoted way
that our folks are
very, very independent.
And it comes from
that background,
that we started with
a lot of senior hires.
And now we're moving into more
like, mid and junior hires.
But for a while there
we had something like 30
or 40 data science
folks, and engineers.
And we had like two junior
folks, or something.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
CHRIS ALBON: Like some
really small number of folks
that were more junior.
And now obviously, like,
we're kind of rebalancing it
because you need to grow.
But when you have so
many senior folks,
you can really forget to
put in guardrails for stuff,
because no one needs
any guardrails.
Well seemingly no one
needs any guardrails.
And then Chris breaks something.
But that kind of approach of
having a very powerful stack,
and a stack with very
little guardrails
is something where you can
only have very senior folks.
And then as you add
more junior folks,
you need to sit down
and say, OK, cool.
We actually need to
document this stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It works for
when you're in startup mode.
It works out pretty well.
But then someone comes on
and they're like, oh, oops,
I deleted everything.
And you're like, why did
you delete everything?
It's not like we
didn't document it.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
MICHELLE CASBON: That
pesky hyper growth stage.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So were
there any major decisions
you made down the road that
you ended up reversing on,
or anything that you
discovered that kind of said,
oh, we need to
swap something out?
MICHELLE CASBON: Or that
you would like to reverse?
Anything that you regret?
CHRIS ALBON: Oh,
anything that I regret?
I think we've done pretty well.
I think we've explored
some technologies.
So, I mean, I'll give you
an example of something
I was going to [INAUDIBLE].
It didn't turn out very well.
We compile our
whole application.
So the whole application that
runs Devoted runs and go.
And recompile that
all the time, which
means that the engineers can
actually rename table names
and recompile, and
those table names
percolate through
the whole system.
The problem with something
like an analytics tool
like Periscope-- it's
hard-wired, like it's
hard-coded, the table names.
And so we needed a
system for the engineers
to be able to change the table
names and that to percolate in.
And right as we
had that problem,
Periscope actually
changed their system
where all the charts are
actually backed up on GitHub.
So we could actually just
like, replace all this stuff
in GitHub and then load it
back in and everything worked.
But there was a moment there
where I was like, wait,
you want to change
all the table names,
like multiple times a day?
That's going to
destroy everything.
Why did I buy Periscope?
And then it was like a week
later they introduced it.
And I was like, whew.
That was lucky.
But the thing is, I
mean, the lesson for me
is that you just don't know.
Right.
We've explored technologies
that just didn't work out.
We haven't explored
it, like, so far.
We've been very good, or
very lucky, one of those two,
where we haven't implemented
something and sat down
and said, oh, that was terrible.
Like why did we do that?
But, I mean, we're
a young company.
I'm sure that'll happen.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's inevitable.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's a scenario that comes up.
Now I know we're running
a little bit out of time.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Wait, wait, wait.
I really want to ask about your
machine learning flashcards.
OK.
So that's one of my favorite
things that you've done.
I know it has helped
me personally.
I would even go so far
as to say that part
of the reason why I have this
job at Google now is because--
CHRIS ALBON: Wow, that's--
MICHELLE CASBON: I
used your flashcards.
CHRIS ALBON: --that
makes me blush.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
like rewind to the point
where you see my name show
up in your purchase history,
and that was when I
was interviewing here.
I'm not kidding.
But I really love them.
And I found them extremely
useful at building out
my TensorFlow model whenever
they asked me about FizzBuzz.
So what prompted you to do that?
I know you were just doing
it for yourself for a while,
but what made you decide
to share that with people?
It's kind of a vulnerable
thing to-- like,
they're all hand-drawn
and they're beautiful,
but I can see, if I had
started to do that, I may not
have wanted to publicize that.
What made you decide to share?
CHRIS ALBON: I think that being
honest and open about stuff
has always been
my best strategy.
And you can see-- you
know, my personal home page
has something like
600 little tutorials
around how I did stuff.
And I wrote those
when I was learning.
So some of 'em are like not
the best way to do things.
And people actually
go into GitHub
and sit down and say, hey, this
is a better way of doing it now
and that kind of stuff.
But I've always been
totally honest about what
I know and don't know.
I don't feel any kind of need to
pretend that I'm not something.
Right.
And I can do that from
a position of privilege,
that when you're the
director of science
at a hyper growth
unicorn company,
you can kind of be
like, hey, I don't
care if you think I'm not good.
Like clearly other people.
MICHELLE CASBON: But
you weren't always that.
CHRIS ALBON: I
wasn't always that.
Yeah.
It's always worked out to me,
just to say I didn't know.
And when I'd made
those flashcards--
I mean, I made 'em because
I knew in interviews
that some of the stuff
you just need to memorize.
Like what's a Brier score?
You just have to know it.
You know.
And it's frankly like, if
you walk in to an interview
and you can write it on the
board, just from memory,
it looks freaking impressive.
But my thing was
just to learn it.
Some of these things, you
know, you have to sit down
and you just memorize it.
Like what is a T-test?
Like what is exactly
happening with everything?
You can read it in a book once.
The best way is just to extract
those pieces of information
and just review it over and
over again and then you know it,
and you have it down,
and you can just pull it
out whenever you need to.
I use those with all
of my job interviews.
That's why I made 'em.
It was a very good experience.
And, you know, I mean,
over the years, sure,
I think there's
been some people who
have said they've been
wrong in various ways.
And I've double-checked
them and then like,
fixed them and
that kind of stuff.
I don't mind being wrong.
It's OK.
MICHELLE CASBON: I think
that's good advice in general,
that it's OK to be
wrong, and that's
where the learning comes from.
That's how we all grow.
CHRIS ALBON: I would
be so surprised
if these days that people
actually sat down and thought
someone who didn't
ask questions clearly
knew everything
that was happening.
Everyone--
MICHELLE CASBON: Good point.
CHRIS ALBON: --you know,
we all know at this point
that everyone doesn't know
everything, particularly
data science where
people come in from so
many different perspectives.
I've had some folks who knew
tons about deep learning,
and they were awesome.
And then they didn't
know basic statistics
because that's just not
part of the training.
It didn't come up.
And it was embarrassing to them.
Right.
It was like, what's a T-test?
I don't know, but I can do
this incredibly complicated
adversarial network thing.
MICHELLE CASBON: I call
these libraries and it works.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
And, you know, or
people who come
in from statistics and they're
like, oh, what's a feature?
And I'll be like,
that's a column.
That kind of stuff, it's just
always worked out to me, just
to be honest and just open.
You know, I started out
because it was useful for me
to grow and learn.
And at this point it's just,
I guess, a personal philosophy
that I just do.
MICHELLE CASBON: Can
you share, maybe one
of your favorite
stories of someone
who's used them and
shared with you,
like, this is how
it impacted my life?
Thank you for providing this.
What's your favorite story
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
So there's been a
few cases of this.
So I sell the cards.
But if anybody can't afford
them, they can just ask me
and I'll give 'em.
Because it's a digital product.
And I've given out thousands
and thousands of cards
at this point.
And every so often, maybe
like once every six months,
someone has come back
to me and said, hey,
you gave me the cards for free.
The cards made me get a job.
I have now bought the cards.
Like that right there.
That's impact.
Right.
Like someone who
couldn't afford it
before because they were
student and they were too poor,
I gave it to them for free.
They ended up
studying it, getting
a job in machine learning, and
then coming back and saying,
hey, like, I was able to
accomplish this because of you.
Let me buy a card
for someone else.
Like let me move
this thing forward.
That is awesome.
There's no other way to say you
have an impact other than that.
MICHELLE CASBON:
That's a great way
to scale your personal impact.
I like that.
OK.
So I think we're
running low on time.
Is there any last thing
you'd like to share with us?
Maybe anything you'd
like to plug or--
CHRIS ALBON: Sure.
We at Devoted are hiring
two folks onto my team,
focusing on analytics.
You know, if you Google
Devoted Health jobs,
I'm pretty sure
the job comes up.
You can go to my Twitter
to actually learn,
where I actually talk about the
job and I'm really open about
what it is and what it isn't.
It would be a perfect
job for a few folks.
MICHELLE CASBON: And we'll add
that link to the show notes.
And again, I've seen it.
There's a lot of
love and care in it.
It's a great description.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And some great
flashcards to help you prepare.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah.
Exactly right.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
We'll have that link in
the show notes as well.
But I can't imagine
anything better
to prepare for an interview with
Chris than his own flashcards.
CHRIS ALBON: Flashcards, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
Does someone ever
like, bring in,
like a printed out
version of the flashcards
to your own interview?
MICHELLE CASBON: And
ask you to autograph it?
CHRIS ALBON: I've seen printed--
I've never seen a
printed one in person.
But a lot of people do
print 'em out and then
send me photos of 'em.
This one institute actually
pasted them on the wall
like wallpaper.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's pretty cool.
CHRIS ALBON: Yeah,
it was pretty sweet.
MICHELLE CASBON: Why
didn't I print them out
to get your autograph.
What was I thinking?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We
can fix that later.
MICHELLE CASBON:
I'll run upstairs.
All right, Chris, thank you
so much for joining us today.
It was great to have you here.
CHRIS ALBON: It's
great to be on.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank you so
much to Chris for coming in.
I mean, it was a super cool
chance for us to chat with him.
You know, he's got some
very interesting things
that I would never
have thought about,
when talking-- especially
about hiring and managing
data science.
Right.
Because, you know, when
I think of data science,
I think of a very technical,
very heavy skill set,
in terms of needing to have
a lot of background there.
But there's so much more empathy
and understanding in how to,
like, kind of work
within a team and really
understand why you are
doing data science,
that it seems like he takes
in as a big factor to being
successful.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
And in many ways it's
fairly straightforward
to evaluate a piece
of code or something
that's very tangible
and very well defined.
But emotional
intelligence is something
that's a lot harder
to define, especially
in the limited amount of
time you have for interviews.
To hear how he tries
to figure that out
in advance before bringing
someone on to the team,
I think that in and
of itself is a skill,
because it's such a difficult
predictor to tease out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So go tweet Chris
if you want a
reunion of "Partially
Derivative," because it
sounds like that will be--
I don't know.
There's some serious
[INAUDIBLE] there.
He sounds like he could be
convinced into doing some more.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
I've already seen a lot of
people asking for reunions,
so not just Chris but
[? Vidia ?] and Jonathan
as well.
It sounds like there's a
lot of demand for that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So,
yeah, go express that,
and maybe we'll all get
to come together and have
a really cool reunion podcast.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
That would be great.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So it was a great
conversation with Chris.
But I do have kind of a
follow up question here,
which we'll just call
our question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what does it mean to
learn in machine learning?
Because machines can't--
I don't think they can--
they can't study like we do.
They don't cram before a test.
They don't stay up till
4:00 AM, not that I ever
did anything like that.
But that learning part
of it is not as easy.
And people talk about
all these networks.
So what does it mean?
What does it mean?
MICHELLE CASBON: So we're
going back to the basics.
Right.
This may seem very
obvious, especially
if you've been in the
field for a while,
but expressing it in words
is surprisingly difficult.
This is a definition
that I got from Chris.
This is one of his flashcards.
This is something
that I came across.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What's the
picture on the flashcard?
MICHELLE CASBON: The picture--
there is no picture on
this one, but the words
are decorated very nicely.
He includes a quote
from Tom Mitchell,
who said this back in 1997.
I'm going to paraphrase it.
If you want the full definition,
you can look at the card.
But this is a great definition
for what the learn means
in machine learning.
To paraphrase Tom Mitchell,
a computer program
is set to learn if it's
performance at specific tasks
improves with experience.
Well that's not all that
different from the way
we learn.
We read books, we
gain experience.
We do tasks and we
improve at them.
And with computers,
machine learning,
you're defining a very
narrow set of tasks.
You're defining that in a way
that gives you a performance
indicator.
So you have a task, a
concrete outcome, and then
you give that computer
access to experience.
So you give it examples of that
task with success predictors
and failure predictors.
And it can take
that information,
ingest it, do something
with it, and then get better
at those tasks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if it
has a way to, more or less,
I mean, like you
said, with experience,
kind of improve or change
its algorithm to figure out
what it's doing
differently, that
would be considered
machine learning.
But if someone were
to come in and modify
the program manually, that's
not considered machine learning.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's correct.
So without changing the
fundamental algorithm-- so
you can change parameters
and hyper parameters.
By the way, if you want
to know the difference
between parameters
and hyper parameters,
Chris has a flashcard for that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Of course.
MICHELLE CASBON: But
as long as you're
just changing parameters and
not the fundamental algorithm
for the program--
so the program has the ability
to change those parameters.
And it does that based
on getting access
to more experience.
So through experience, if it
can update itself in order
to get better at these tasks
so that its performance
indicators get better
and better and better,
that's machine learning.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I have
to buy these flashcards.
Because if all of
that is on one card--
and there's a lot of cards.
There's no shortage of them.
Right?
MICHELLE CASBON: They
are hundreds of cards.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, this is stuff
that I really just
don't have a good background in.
So it's super cool to hear that.
And I think I like
that definition.
Right.
It's very simple.
Like, if it can learn from its
experience to make changes,
and usually in a positive
way, hopefully, it's
the learning part
of machine learning.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's straightforward.
So if you want to find out
more, including the definition
of a partial derivative, buy
a pack of Chris' flashcards.
Because who knows,
they might even
help you land your next job.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So definitely some very
cool resources in there.
We'll make sure we have
the links to the flashcards
in the show notes.
I think we're almost
out of time here.
Michelle, before we go,
anything cool coming up?
Any traveling?
Any new cards you're
going to pitch to Chris
to add to the flashcard deck?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
So I'll be in San Francisco
for the near future.
I'm working on an event--
I'm curating the ML for
Developers Track for QCon.
That's in San Francisco
on November 13.
But other than that I'll
be right here in town.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
sounds very exciting.
So what's QCon all about?
MICHELLE CASBON: QCon is--
I believe it's InfoQ
that puts this on.
And I've spoken
at a few of them,
but this is the first
time I'm curating a track.
And they're deep dives.
They're almost hour-long talks.
They're a bit different
from other conferences.
But I have very much
enjoyed them in the past.
And I'm very much
looking forward
to being part of this event.
It's the first time that
I've been part of it
as an organizer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if
you're around San Francisco
on November 13, it sounds
like your plans have already
been made for you.
We'll make sure to have a link
to that in the show notes.
I'll be hanging
around San Francisco.
I'm super-excited because I just
launched the "Beyond your Bill"
series, which, you know, we've
been talking to a lot of people
about helping them understand
how their GCP billing and cost
management tool-- like there's
a bunch of tools in there.
But like, what are they?
How do they work?
How do I know what I'm
actually spending my money on?
All these really,
really important things.
So I'm super-excited
to launch that,
and we're working on a bunch of
other content surrounding that,
to help people, again,
get that understanding of,
how do I measure my costs?
What tools are available to me?
And then really, how do I
actually use those tools?
MICHELLE CASBON:
Because in addition
to using the right
tool for the job,
you also need to understand how
much each of those tools costs?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Right?
I mean it's like it's such
a bare metal kind of thing.
[BUZZ]
Maybe bare metal wasn't
the right word there.
[LAUGHING]
It's such a basic concept
that you need to understand.
Right.
Like, look, I have all
these tools available to me.
But if I'm going
to use all of them,
I'm also going to pay for them.
It's something to be
aware of when you're
working on all these things IS
like, yes, the power of Google,
and the power of all these
computers around the globe
are at your fingertips.
But they all have different
costs associated with them too.
MICHELLE CASBON:
And with great power
comes great responsibility.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And on that
note, I think we'll call it.
Thanks to everyone for tuning
into our data science episode.
And we'll see you all next week.
MICHELLE CASBON: We'll
see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It turns
out with machine learning,
you can still write
infinite for loops.
[LAUGHING]
And we don't have to
worry about Skynet,
because some programmers
just make mistakes.
MICHELLE CASBON: You know,
with every piece of software,
we can just write infinite for.
[APPLAUSE]